comme promis maintenant nous retrouvons
notre invité Nicolas Sarkozi bonsoir
bonsoir d commençons par le cas baptisti
si vous le voulez bien non pas peut-être
sur le fond du dossier on comprend que
la France puisse coopérer avec un pays
ami l'Italie qui est une démocratie mais
sur le calendrier pourquoi cette
arrestation intervient maintenant en
pleine campagne c'est extraordinaire
David Pujadas je voyais que la gauche
était pas contente mais quel est le
gouvernement italien si céit un
gouvernement de gauche c'est la gauche
italienne qui a demandé l'extradition de
Monsieur baptistique qui est accusé
d'assassinat excusz du peu c'est la
justice italienne indépendante qui a
lancé un mandat d'arrêt international
nous sommes en Europe au nom de quoi la
police française qui disposait de
renseignement ne devrait pas les
communiquer simplement parce que nous
sommes à un mois et demi de la campagne
électorale mais quel est le rapport une
pure coincidence mais quel est le
rapport d'Avid Pujadas voilà un Italien
accusé d'assassinat en Italie qui est
arrêté au Brésil quel est le rapport
avec la campagne électorale et qu'est-ce
que propose la gauche française qu'on
laisse courir ceux qui sont accusés
d'assassinat et que je demande à la
police française de ne pas coopérer avec
la justice italienne donc ce calendrier
est une pure coincidence mais bien
naturellement et où est la polémique
qu'est-ce que je devais faire il il peut
y avoir des poursuites en France contre
ceux qui ont aidé Césaré baptisti dans
sa fuite vous êtes pour je suis pour
l'indépendance de la justice c'est pas
mon problème je suis ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur baptisti est accusé
d'assassinat il s'est enfui au Brésil la
justice italienne a demandé que toutes
les polices du monde coopèrent pour
qu'il puissent être devant ses juges
c'est ce qui s'est passé il y a vraiment
pas lieu à polémique alors c'est
critique renvoie une fois encore à votre
double casquette ministre de l'Intérieur
candidat à la présidentielle vous avez
rencontré Jacques Chirac ce matin est-ce
que vous avez fixé la date de votre
départ du ministère de l'intérieur alors
deux remarques la première c'est que
j'ai vu que la gauche trouvait que j'en
faisais pas assez comme ministre de
l'Intérieur trop occupé que j'étais par
la campagne électorale voilà maintenant
qu'on me reproche le contraire d'en
faire trop alors nous en avons parlé ce
matin avec le président de la République
il appartiendra au président de la
République qui m'a nommé avec le Premier
ministre d'annoncer lui-même la date de
mon départ qui interviendra avant la fin
du mois de mars comme je l'ai toujours
dit c'est lui qui l'annoncera bien sûr
puisque c'est lui qui m'a nommé j'ajoute
pour que les choses soient claires que
je serai le premier candidat à une
élection présidentielle qui s'imposera
d'abandonner toutes ses responsabilités
à un peu plus d'un mois de l'échéance
présid ti ce que n'avait jamais fait ni
monsieur Jospin ni aucun autre candidat
et ce qui me permettra d'aller à la
rencontre des Français en toute liberté
est-ce que la date et les modalités du
soutien que le Président de la
République doit vous apporter a été fixé
ben nous en avons parlé il lui
appartiendra de dire ce qu'il en pense
et en ce qui concerne les
modalités c'est pas moi de les annoncer
alors on entre dans une nouvelle phase
dans une nouvelle phase de la campagne
on disait à partir de ce soir minuit
avec la liste des candidats officiels 12
candidats c'est trop c'est bien non
c'est bien je trouve d'ailleurs vous
savez très bien ce que j'en pense qu'il
était parfaitement normal qu'un certain
nombre de candidats et leur signature je
pense que l'élection présidentielle
c'est un moment où il faut que les
Français puissent penser librement et je
suis parfois stupéfait qu'on les empêche
de penser librement on n pas le droit de
parler de l'Euro sous prétexte d'être un
mauvais européen on n pas le droit de
parler de l'identité au prétexte qu'on
serait nationaliste on n' pas le droit
de parler de l'immigration au prétexte
qu'on serait raciste c'est la façon dont
on en parle vous en parle je vois pas ce
qu'il y a de criticable je pense que ce
sont des vrais sujet et je ne veux pas
que les Français soient prisonniers
d'une pensée unique d'une élite qui
dirait voilà comment il faut penser
voilà comment il faut faire parce
qu'avec ça David Pujadas est-ce qu'on se
pose la question pourquoi il y a eu 55 %
de Français qui ont voté pour le nom
pourquoi il y a un Français sur deux qui
vote pas et pourquoi Monsieur Le Pen
s'est retrouvé au deuxième tour si nous
on fait de la politique
comme d'habitude si on ne change rien
pourquoi voulez-vous que des millions de
gens a voter si on ne peut rien si on ne
pense rien et si on a le droit de rien
dire moi je veux être libre et je dis au
français pensez librement abordons
quelques uns des thèmes il y a eu
beaucoup de promesses dans cette
campagne y compris de votre côté l'une
d'entre elles c'est le plein emploi dans
5 ans c'est-à-dire 4 à 5 % de chômage
est-ce que c'est réaliste oui c'est pas
une promesse c'est un engagement c'est
tout à fait différent d'ailleurs vous
l'avez vu l'Institut Rex code institut
économique totalement indépendant proche
du patronat a noté la totalité des
programmes économiques ils ont dit quoi
que le programme que je présentait était
crédible qui créerit 1,3 % de croissance
qui créerit de l'emploi que tous les
autres programmes en déduiraiit en
détruiraient alors je dis au français ça
fait 30 ans qu'on vous explique que le
plein emploi c'est pas possible on ment
et je je le prouve parce que le plein
emploi c'est possible en Angleterre
c'est possible dans les démocraties du
nord de l'Europe c'est possible au
Canada c'est un autre système étsunis je
le dis pourquoi on va réussir le plein
emploi et je m'y engage sur 5 ans parce
que le problème de la France c'est pas
qu'on travaille trop c'est qu'on
travaille pas assz et que l'erreur qui a
été faite c'est le partage du temps de
travail alors que moi ce que je veux
c'est donner un travail à chacun je veux
valoriser le travail respecter le
travail récompenser le travail c'est
quand même extraordinaire que nous
soyons le seul pays au monde qui empêche
les gens qui veulent gagner plus de
pouvoir le faire alors vous avez dit que
vous alliez détaxer desfisc iser les
heures supplémentaires ça suffit pour
créer le le plein emploi ah bah déjà ça
permet vous rendez compte quelqu'un qui
est auos SMIG qui travaille 50 minutes
de plus par jour on peut lui offrir 15 %
d'augmentation de salaire mais je pose
une question David Pujadas à quoi ça
sert les RTT quand on n' pas de quoi
payer des vacances à ses enfants quand
il reste rien après avoir travaillé bien
sûr que c'est très choquant qu'il existe
des pauvres parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
travail mais c'est un scandale qu'il
existe des pauvres qui travaillent parce
que quand on a travaillé tout le mois
qui reste rien qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire alors je prends un deuxième
engagement je veux que tous les Français
qui soient licenciés économique a la
chance de bénéficier d'un contrat avec
le service public de l'emploi qui
débouchera soit sur une formation soit
sur un emploi c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui pas le cas aujourd'hui c'est
une proposition qu'on a élaboré avec
Jean-Louis borlot qui est une très bonne
proposition je ne veux pas que aucun
Français soit condamné à l'inactivité
parce que quand on est condamné à
l'inactivité on perd la dignité de
soi-même et puis trème engagement je
veux que tous les jeunes des quartiers
sachent que si je suis élu président de
la République je me battrai pour que
chacun d'entre eux est une formation
qualifiante d'une année qui débouchera
sur un emploi pourquoi parce que je veux
lutter contre l'isiveté contre les
trafics parce que je veux donner la
chance de vivre de son travail à tous
les jeunes Français alors on va me dire
ça coûte de l'argent non ça en coûte
beaucoup moins de mettre les gens au
travail que de les laisser sans travail
perdre même jusqu'au respect de le même
alors autre domaine les institutions l'a
vu question simple réponse simple est-ce
que vous êtes favorable au mandat unique
c'est-à-dire à la fin du cumul des
mandats comme le propose par exemp
penser qus sont les problèmes de la
France le chômage le pouvoir d'achat une
bonne école pour ses enfants l'idée
qu'on se fait de la France l'intégration
des Français est-ce que vraiment vous
rencontrez une personne qui vous dise je
suis traumatisé par nos institutions
c'est pour la santé du système politique
c'est une maladie française que de
vouloir changer la constitution tous les
5 matins c'est d'ailleurs une maladie
française que de penser quand on vote
une loi on résout un problème nous avons
de bonnes institution il y a quelques
changements à faire mais ce qu'il faut
changer c'est le chômage le plein emploi
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est
l'immigration qu'il faut maîtriser c'est
pas les problèmes de 6e de 7e ou de 8e
République question sur la campagne cgen
royale se dit peut-être favorable à un
débat avec ses principaux concurrents
avant le premier tour vous vous y êtes
aussi favorable bah c'est c'est quand
même une drôle d'idée de demander
l'organisation de débat à un moment on
peut plus les organiser puisqu'il y a 12
candidats comment vous allez faire
puisqu'on est tous à la street égalité
si Madame Royale voulait un débat il
fallait qu'elle le fasse avant je vrais
faire une deuxième remarque c'est les
Français qui vont choisir les candidats
qui seront au deè tour je n'en sais rien
alors il y aura fatalement un débat au
2e tour parce que les Français auront
choisi ceux qui seront 2e tour moi je
vais faire campagne jusqu'au 22 avril
d'abord pour être qualifi pour le 2è
tour c'est pas les sondages ce sont les
Français qui décideront et chacun
d'entre nous acceptons le verdict des
Français merci Nicolas Sarkozi d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sachez que
François baayrou est l'invité de
questions ouvertes ce soir après ce
journal il répondra aux questions de
Gill Leclerc